SIGNATURE GENES, AS I ALWAYS DO,
AND SNEAKERS.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT JOE BIDEN NEEDS TO PICK
UP THE PHONE AND I SUGGEST CALL
MAR-A-LAGO AND, YEAH, BRING
UNITY TO THE COUNTRY AS HE SAYS
HE SO DESPERATELY WANTS AND
THANK PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE A FEW MOMENTS AGO HE
TRIED TO TAKE CREDIT FOR
EVERYTHING THAT DONALD TRUMP DID
ON COVID-19.
THREE VACCINES THANKS TO
DONALD TRUMP’S OPERATION
WARP SPEED.
THERE WERE ALREADY A MILLION
VACCINES BEING ADMINISTERED TO
PEOPLES ARMS EVERY DAY WHEN
BIDEN WAS SWORN IN, 36 MILLION
DOSES AT ALREADY BEEN
DISTRIBUTED.
ACCORDING TO JOE IT WAS THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT
STEPPED IN, HEROICALLY SAVED
AMERICA FROM COVID-19, NONE OF
THIS IS TRUE.
WHERE’S THE UNITY, JOE?
>> President Biden: I’M USING
EVERY POWER I HAVE AS PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES TO PUT US
ON A WAR FOOTING TO GET THE JOB
DONE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE HYPERBOLE BUT I
MEAN IT, WAR FOOTING.
AND THANK GOD WE ARE MAKING SOME
REAL PROGRESS NOW.
NOW BECAUSE ALL THE WORK WE’VE
DONE EMMA WE WILL HAVE ENOUGH
VACCINE SUPPLY FOR ALL ADULTS IN
AMERICA BY THE END OF MAY.
THAT’S MONTHS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
>> Sean: THAT WOULD BE
MODERNA, PFIZER, THAT WOULD BE
JOHNSON & JOHNSON AND THAT WOULD
BE HER PREDECESSOR,
PRESIDENT TRUMP, OPERATION
WARP SPEED.
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
PRESIDENT, HE DIDN’T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THAT VACCINE
AND HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
MARS ROVER EITHER.
THERE YOU HAVE IT.
JOE BIDEN, UNITY PRESIDENT THAT
HE IS TAKING CREDIT FOR SOMEONE
ELSE’S WORK.
JOE, YOU WANT UNITY?
WHY DON’T YOU JUST THINK
DONALD TRUMP?
YOU WANT US ALL TO GET ALONG,
YOU SAY.
NO TRUMP, NO VACCINE, JOE.
STOP TAKING CREDIT FOR SOMETHING
FRANKLY YOU HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH.
NOTHING.
BUT I DO NEED TO GIVE JOE BIDEN
A CONGRATULATIONS TONIGHT.
HE STAYED UP IN OUR PAST HIS
BETTY TIME AFTER DAYS AND DAYS
OF PRACTICE.
HE WAS ABLE TO READ FROM THE
TELEPROMPTER FOR ALMOST 20 WHOLE
MINUTES WITHOUT MAKING A TOTAL
FULL LOT OF HIMSELF.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS IS, C,
HANNITY, HE DID IT, HE DID IT!
JOHNNY HIT THE BASEBALL!
GOOD JOB!
IS THAT THE LOWEST BAR POSSIBLE
FOR A PRESIDENT?
ISN’T IT A LITTLE KIND OF SAD
THAT WE EVEN HAVE TO WONDER OR
EVEN DISCUSS IT?
IT’S KIND OF SAD TO ME.
LET’S BE CLEAR, BIDEN’S ABILITY
TO REMAIN LUCID TONIGHT FOR 20
LONG MINUTES SHOULDN’T BE CAUSE
FOR CELEBRATION.
THIS IS A GUY WHO IS CLEARLY NOT
DOING WELL AND THE LAST THREE
WEEKS ALONE HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
ALARMING.
THAT IS THE SAD TRUTH.
SINCE THE EARLY DAYS OF THE
CAMPAIGN, WE HAVE BEEN WATCHING
JOE AND HIS DAILY STRUGGLES,
THAT IS WHEN HIS CAMPAIGN RARELY
WOULD ALLOW HIM TO LEAVE THE
BASEMENT BUNKER, YES, RARE, BUT
NOW JOE IS CLEARLY GETTING WORSE
AND AGAIN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN JUST
THESE PAST THREE WEEKS, NOT
TONIGHT, HE PRACTICED AND
PRACTICED AND PRACTICED AND LO
AND BEHOLD HE GOT THROUGH THE
SPEECH WITHOUT FUMBLING THE
BALL.
THIS IS THE LAST THREE WEEKS
LEADING INTO TONIGHT AND THE
HOURS AND HOURS OF PRACTICE
BEFORE TONIGHT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: I WANT TO
THANK THE FORMER GENERAL, I KEEP
CALLING HIM GENERAL.
MY -- THE GUY WHO RUNS THAT OVER
THERE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF ECONOMISTS
LEFT, RIGHT, AND CENTER FROM
WALL STREET TO THE PRIVATE
ECONOMIC POLLING INITIATIVES.
AM I SUPPOSED TO SPEAK?
REPRESENTATIVES SHOW --
SHEILA JACKSON LEE, AL GREEN,
SYLVIA GARCIA -- EXCUSE ME AND
WHAT AM I DOING HERE?
THAT OVER 500 -- I HAVE A CARD,
I CARRY A CARD WITH ME EVERY DAY
WITH THE TOTAL NUMBER OF FOLKS
WHO HAVE BEEN AFFECTED.
>> Sean: OKAY.
SO YOU SEE WHY JOE HAS GONE 50
DAYS WITHOUT OFFICIAL PRESS
CONFERENCE.
THAT’S A HIGHER BAR, IT’S GOING
TO TAKE A LOT MORE PRACTICE.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION KNOWS THE
BIGGEST LIABILITY FOR JOE BIDEN
IS JOE BIDEN HIMSELF.
YOU CAN SPARE SCRIPT A
PRIME TIME ADDRESS IN PRACTICE,
PRACTICE.
YOU CAN SCRIPT THE STATE OF THE
UNION AND LET ME BE HONEST,
THAT’S THE EASIEST SPEECH FOR
ANY PRESIDENT TO YOU WALK IN TO
APPLAUSE, SHAKE A FEW HANDS,
LEAD A FEW RUNS, YOU GET MORE
APPLAUSE.
MORE REST TIME, BUT IT’S A
LITTLE HARDER TO SCRIPT OR PRESS
CONFERENCE.
THAT’S GOING TO TAKE FOR MORE
PRACTICE AND OF COURSE A
COMPLIANT NEWS MEDIA AND WHEN
JOE ACTUALLY DECIDES TO HOLD AN
OFFICIAL PRESS OR, SO FAR IT’S
LONGER THAN ANY PRESIDENT IN THE
LAST HUNDRED YEARS, I THINK
ADMINISTRATION WILL PROBABLY OF
COURSE TRY TO ORCHESTRATE THE
ENTIRE EVENT JUST LIKE THEY DID
THE FEW TIMES HE DID IT ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL PRESELECTING A
HANDFUL OF PRO BIDEN REPORTERS.
IN THE MEANTIME THEY GENTLY
DON’T WANT JOE ANSWERING ANY
PROMPTER -- ON PROCTOR
QUESTIONS.
LAST THREE DAYS, ONLY ONE EVENT
ON JOE’S SCHEDULE.
JUST ONE.
AFTER JOE SIGNED THE MASSIVE
$2 TRILLION SCHUMER-PELOSI
PAYOFF INTO LAW, ONLY 9% IS
EMERGENCY COVID RELIEF.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: GOT IT.
THANK YOU ALL, APPRECIATE IT.
[INDISCERNIBLE].
>> Sean: HE DID GOOD TONIGHT,
HE DIDN’T HAVE JOE BIDEN OR
KAMALA HARRIS NEXT TO HIM.
THAT’S A RARE THING.
JUST TO PUT THIS INTO
PERSPECTIVE, WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS IN OFFICE,
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA MOB, THEY
HAD A MENTAL BREAKDOWN IF TRUMP
DIDN’T RESPOND TO JIM ACOSTA AT
A FAKE NEWS CNN AND PERSONALITY
AT HIS INSULTS HURLED ACROSS THE
WHITE HOUSE LAWN.
NOW JOE BIDEN SIGNS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST BOONDOGGLE SPENDING
BILLS THAT HAS ZERO BASICALLY
FOR EMERGENCY COVID RELIEF.
NOT A LOT, 9%.
AFTER REFUSING TO GIVE ONE
SINGLE REST CONFERENCE DURING
HIS ENTIRE TIME IN OFFICE, THE
MEDIA MOB BARELY YAWNS.
THERE’S A GUY IN THE OVAL OFFICE
ALLEGEDLY RUNNING THE COUNTRY
WHO APPEARS TO BE STRUGGLING
COGNITIVELY WHEN THE MOB CANNOT
BE BOTHERED TO DO THEIR JOBS.
THEY ARE ACTIVELY WILLFULLY
PUTTING THEIR HEADS IN THE SAND.
THAT WOULD BE NBC, ABC, CBS,
MSDNC, FAKE NEWS CNN.
DO ANY OF YOU GUYS HAVE ANY NEWS
DIVISIONS AT ALL?
DO HAVE JOURNALISTS WORKING FOR
YOU ARE NOT?
BE HONEST WITH YOU AND YOUR
VIEWERS.
IF YOU’RE JUST A MOUTHPIECE FOR
THE DNC, IN OTHER WORDS IF YOU
WANT TO BE A TALK SHOW HOST.
I’M A MEMBER OF THE PRESS BUT I
AM A TALK SHOW HOST.
I HAVE OPINIONS, I TELL
EVERYBODY UP FRONT I’M
REGISTERED CONSERVATIVE AND YEAH
I LIKE DONALD TRUMP AS PRESIDENT
BECAUSE DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, THE COVERAGE WAS
A LITTLE MORE AGGRESSIVE, DON’T
YOU THINK?
ACCORDING TO NEARLY ALL OF THEIR
COVERAGE, DONALD TRUMP COULD
INTO A SINGLE THING RIGHT.
IN FACT, THEY PREDICTED THE
PRESIDENT’S PLAN TO DEVELOP AND
DISTRIBUTE COVID-19 VACCINES --
YES, KNOWN AS OPERATION
WARP SPEED -- WOULD BE AN UTTER
FAILURE.
HE NOT ONLY GOT IT DONE AND GOT
A MILLION IN PEOPLES ARMS A DAY,
36 MILLION TOTAL, BUT HE DID IT
WHILE BEING IMPEACHED AND TRIED
TWICE.
PRETTY AMAZING, YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER.
>> I THINK THIS IS JUST FURTHER
EVIDENCE THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAD NO PLAN FOR
DISTRIBUTION.
OPERATION WARP SPEED WAS REALLY
JUST A PLAN TO ADDRESS MARKET
FAILURES AND MANUFACTURING AND
DEVELOPING AND MANUFACTURING OF
VACCINES.
>> WE WILL HAVE A VACCINE BY THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
IS THAT POSSIBLE IN YOUR VIEW?
>> OH, YOU KNOW, IF ANOTHER DATE
OF POTUS IN WONDERLAND HERE.
IT IS PREPOSTEROUS TO MAKE THAT
STATEMENT.
>> OUR WARNING, THAT KIND OF
TIMELINE MAY BE OVERLY AMBITIOUS
AND SOME HAVE EVEN ARGUED IT’S
PERHAPS DANGEROUS.
>> CORONAVIRUS VACCINE TRUMP
SAYS COULD COME OF THIS YEAR,
HAPPY TALK THAT HE’S DOING ABOUT
THE VACCINE, EXPERTS SAY HE
WOULD NEED A MIRACLE TO BE
RIGHT.
>> HERE’S THE THING, YOU CANNOT
TALK YOURSELF INTO A VACCINE.
THE FASTEST A VACCINE HAS EVER
BEEN PRODUCED FROM START TO
FINISH IS FIVE YEARS.
>> Sean: YOU’RE RIGHT.
DONALD TRUMP DID IT IN 1 AND YOU
NEVER GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR
ANYTHING.
NOTHING HE DOES IS RIGHT.
THAT WASN’T HAPPY TALK, WAS IT?
OPERATION WARP SPEED THANKFULLY
FOR THE SAKE OF THE COUNTRY AND
THE WORLD WAS A HUGE SUCCESS.
THANK GOD FOR OUR GREAT MEDICAL
RESEARCHERS AND SCIENTISTS AND
DOCTORS AND FIRST RESPONDERS.
THEY DID AN AMAZING JOB.
WE ALL OWE THEM A DEBT OF
GRATITUDE, BUT THERE WILL BE NO
RETRACTIONS, NO APOLOGIES, THEY
WILL NEVER CORRECT THE RECORD.
INSTEAD, THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
ACT AS CHEERLEADERS FOR THE